Mike, please don’t leave me here, bro.
Tellus, you’re retired.
It’s not safe for you to be on your own.
I’m a year younger than you.
I’ll come visit...
Maybe during my bye week.
That’s not till Week 9...
Brothers never visit.
So it’s pretty neat here.
You can help the retired Cowboys call bingo games.
Ok, so based on this formation...
I’m guessing the next ball will be N24.
What he said!
Um...hey, Witt.
Oh...
It’s Marty.
When I moved into the retirement home...
crime dropped 100 percent!
Here we see our exercise programs.
My in-season record is 25,000...
but I think I can beat that now!
I’m sure Canada will call soon, T.O.!
They still think they can play...
This place sucks.
I gotta get the f--k out of here.
Martellus, you’re 31.
There’s nothing out there for you anymore.
One of us... One of us...
I survived a 28-3 deficit—
I’m not going out like this!
Cutty, I need help!
Cigarette?
There we go miscommunicating again.
AHHHHHH!!
♪ Retired Athletes Have No Life. ♪